Today we're making some Turkish eggs.
So I started off by straining some of Daniel's homemade yogurt
in a cheese cloth
and hung that so it could get a bit thicker.
Then I wash my butter.
I also like to run it under some cold water
to get it really nice and washed,
and then I add some salts,
and then we use that butter for our base.
So we cook the butter,
and when it was nice and bubbly,
I added my cayenne flakes,
smoked paprika, and cumin,
and let that infuse together.
It smelled so good.
We made some sourdough bread,
and while that was cooking,
I made the jalapeno parsley, olive oil drizzle.
So I smashed the jalapenos,
chopped up the parsley,
added them together,
drizzled some olive oil and salt,
and then the yogurt was a lot thicker by this point,
so we added some salt and fresh garlic, and then pepper,
some dill and mix that together.
And then I got started on the poached eggs.
So I put them in water and vinegar and let them sit for, like,
10 minutes.
And that really is the trick to having the perfect poached egg.
And then we plated it.
So we put garlic,
the garlic yogurt on the bottom,
we drizzled the jalapeno parsley on top of that,
then the poached eggs, and then your cayenne butter on top of that,
and then you just get your sourdough toast and eat it.
It was literally The most delicious thing ever.
And Daniel liked it too.